digamos que tenemos una función fx y fx
va a ser igual a x sobre la raíz de x
cuadrada más 1 y me gustaría que
pensemos acerca de cuál sería el límite
de fx el límite de fx cuando x se
aproxima a infinito pero también cuando
tenemos el límite de fx pero x se
aproxima a menos infinito y lo vamos a
realizar pero primero que todo esto no
es una forma muy rigurosa de realizar
las cosas pero de forma intuitiva vamos
a pensar en qué tanto se aproxima a un
valor dichos límites y todo esto depende
de los valores que vaya tomando x pueden
ser valores muy muy grandes hablando
positivamente o también números
negativamente grandes entonces lo
haremos para cuando x se aproxima a más
infinito y cuando x se aproxima a menos
infinito ahora bien si observamos el
numerador nosotros únicamente tenemos un
término que es x
en el denominador tenemos dos términos
dentro de la raíz que está por aquí
entonces conforme x tome valores muy muy
grandes
tanto positivo como negativamente al
tener la x cuadrada realmente va a
dominar a este uno que tenemos por acá
entonces no nos va a afectar mucho que
digamos que esto aproxima a hacer x
sobre la raíz de x cuadrada claro que
esto es válido pero para cuando x
aproxima valores muy grandes para que
domina este uno que tenemos por aquí
entonces ahora que tenemos esto de aquí
que converja a esta a esta expresión
también podemos decir que al calcular la
raíz de x cuadrada podemos tener dos
raíces la raíz positiva y la raíz
negativa entonces esto es equivalente a
que pongamos aquí que sería el valor
absoluto para cuando x se aproxima a
valores muy grandes o también valores
muy grandes pero hablando negativamente
y otra forma de decir esto u otra forma
de expresar lo es restableciendo la
siguiente expresión entonces nos
quedaría que sería igual
cuando x se aproxima a infinito de x
sobre el valor absoluto de x y bueno
ahora cuando x toma valores positivos el
valor absoluto simplemente nos deja la
misma expresión entonces sería como
dividir un número sobre sí mismo que
sería igual a 1 y en el caso de cuando x
se aproxima menos infinito en la parte
superior en la del numerador nos va a
quedar un término negativo dividido
sobre un término positivo por lo tanto
esta expresión de aquí va a hacer un
número sobre sí mismo pero negativamente
entonces esto va a ser igual a menos 1
es simplemente algo muy similar a lo que
realizamos arriba es dividir un número
sobre sí mismo sólo que en este caso la
función del valor absoluto si afecta a
nuestro límite entonces es igual a menos
1 y ahora bien tenemos estas dos
expresiones y podemos utilizarlas para
graficar entonces aquí tenemos nuestro
eje de las yes y por acá vamos a tener
nuestro eje
de las equis y con la cual vamos a tener
dos asín totas horizontales pues tenemos
una cinta horizontal para cuando llegue
es igual a 1 por aquí tenemos que este
valor pertenece aquí a igual a 1 y vamos
a dibujar nuestra sin tota y luego por
acá vamos a tener la otra sin tota
horizontal para cuando es igual a menos
1 también vamos a dibujar dicho valor
para cuando es igual a menos 1 y ahora
hay que visualizar este punto
analizando cuando x es igual a 0 para
ver desde donde partimos entonces
efe de 0 va a ser igual a 0 sobre la
raíz de 0 + 1 lo que es igual
entonces vemos que partimos del origen
nuestra gráfica cuando x se aproxima a
infinito que va tomando valores muy muy
grandes tiende a acercarse a dicha sin
total para cuando hoy es igual a 1 pero
espera creo que no lo estoy dibujando
tan claramente me estoy extendiendo
demasiado la gráfica se comportaría algo
así para cuando x ha tomando valores
cada vez mayores partimos del origen y
lo voy a dibujar con otro color para que
quede un poco más claro viene aquí se
aproxima a igualdad a una nuestra sin
tota horizontal y obviamente jamás la
toca y luego entonces para cuando x se
aproxima a menos infinito tendemos a
aproximarnos
de igual a menos 1 y luego entonces esto
de aquí es igual a fx y podemos ir
verificando todo esto dando valores en
la calculadora y trazando todo esto con
mayores puntos en una especie de gráfica
dora o algo así pero bueno simplemente
quiero abordar otra situación que es
importante pues si te diste cuenta como
el análisis que utilizamos aquí para
simplificar nuestro límite fue ver qué
valores dominan tanto en el numerador
como en el denominador y verá que
convergen este tipo de funciones y luego
vienen trazar sus asín totales para los
límites infinitos